2020 has been a frightening year viruses
murder hornets kamala harris so since
halloween is upon us
my producer compiled a few of the most
horrifying political videos
of the year but first i'd like to
mention this video is sponsored by my
bookie
the best place to place bets on sports
and political events
of all kinds more about them later in
the meantime
let's check out the first spooky video
i i see where this is going
what do we have here spooky spooky
spooky
and creepy
oh it's funny it's joe
um come on man candy's for the kids well
maybe he forgot
wait a minute you you look familiar
who are you
are we gonna let her get away with this
she took everything
that is very scary there are a lot of
different messages in this video i mean
you saw from the very beginning we smell
children you know you knew this was
going to be a biden video
but it is the case if biden gets elected
he won't be the president
what people are saying is it's going to
be kamala harris but i actually don't
even think it's going to be her i don't
think she's
any less of an empty suit than biden i
don't think she's any more substantial
than he is
i think they're both just they they lick
their index finger they put it up in the
wind and they figure out which way it's
blowing
the scary thing is that they will
empower the liberal establishment the
bureaucracy
the activists the media the big tackle
all those guys they're going to empower
them
to be acting through biden who knows or
kamala harris as though they were just
zombies which in many ways
they are and that is very very spooky
let's roll the second one
[Applause]
hey honey
[Applause]
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump oh great yes trump won good news
i thought you could only be president
two times
wow not
[Applause]
it will anymore stop trump forever
vote him out wow
that video got me so excited
for president trump's third term and his
fourth term i hope maybe his fifth term
too if we were so lucky
the reason that this is such a
ridiculous scare tactic for the left
is the left right now right this very
second is saying we need to pack the
courts like
fdr right that's where they got the idea
of court packing from we need a new deal
from fdr right they actually stole the
name of the policy that fdr put forward
for their new environmental thing
and actually the fact that the supreme
court struck down a lot of the new deal
was the reason that fdr talked about
packing the course in the first place
but we
we need to throw out trump because he
might seek a third term
just like wait for it wait for it oh
fdr right who saw it not just a third
term but a fourth term too and the only
reason we ever got rid of him is because
he died in office
kind of confused messaging isn't it we
need to be exactly like
fdr who was an american monarch but
oh no trump might stay in office man i
wish trump would stay in office
unfortunately something tells me he
won't
but man would that be so fun i wish if i
if you ask me right now to place my bet
will trump run for a third term i would
have to bet no though i would certainly
ask him to it is betting season right
now in my bookie
if you weren't already way too much into
politics right now
you can make a little bit money on it
too with my bookie you can bet on things
like the winner of the presidential
election
even the day that the loser will concede
the race
whether you have been betting for years
or you're ready to play for the first
time my bookie is your go-to
this season with the biggest online
selection of bets and props my bookie
has made it simple to win and easy to
withdraw your
cash i have been known to place a few
political bets i placed a bet
with my pal ben shapiro last election
cycle and i have the framed
check to prove it there we go thank you
absolutely no
no no i'm very much looking forward to
placing some more bets on ben so i can
shake him down by his ankles and get
some more
good political gambling money out of him
head on over to my bookie to create an
account
just use the promo code knowles kwles to
claim your 100
deposit match all the way up to a
thousand dollars that means if you put a
hundred dollars in
they will give you another hundred
dollars it's an easy way to jumpstart
your bankroll nfl nba mlb everything
else they've got it all on tap it's
never too late
to get started on your winning season
over at
my bookie okay now let's get back into
the halloween
2020 mindset get into some scary
spooky horrifying political videos
excuse me
where's your mask that's good this is
actually genuinely kind of creepy
um i left it inside it's
because i'm out here doing laundry
even still you should be wearing a mask
just like me
you never know who you might come into
contact with and what they might have
this is genuinely pretty creepy i
haven't seen any moving trucks here
lately
but the place furnished
look i've got a bunch inside take it
you'll be glad you did thank you for
your time
he knows
[Applause]
[Music]
did not see that going there i guess at
a very basic
political level the point was you think
that the
the masked people are scary but really
it's the non-mask wearing people who are
scary
and they're killers and they're
murderers or something i guess i mean it
may also just be the case
that this guy is a horror filmmaker
obviously very talented he's very well
shot
a little short and he just wanted a
gimmick to tie in with the
to to make it kind of political so it
goes viral but it's very very well done
short
even if if it does have a political
message of the political message
is a little a weak a little unpersuasive
you didn't really expect what was going
to happen there i guess none of us
can quite expect what's going to happen
over the next two weeks will we have a
happy ending
well we have a very scary ending we will
have to wait
and see
you